で 次のセクションが始まります
で いわゆる挫折しないためということで
まあ仏教から我々はいくらかいくらか言いましたけど
前の六項目の中でもね
もうちょっとまとめてみようかなと
まあ一番目はもう怠けということですね
もう怠けには人生の中で立場がないんですよ
怠けは砕かないと矛盾に遭遇するんです
だから我々はたとえ本能といっても
怠けそのものがすごい危険なんです
それが不幸なんですよ
怠けに負けるともう死ぬ羽目になるんです
瞬時に死ねばありがたいんですけども
もうすごくもう苦しませて苦しませてゆっくり死なせるんだから
だからまず怠けを砕くということは
怠けを砕く方法 前も書きました
あのプロセスを楽しむことですね
で 生きることというのは精進なんですよ
精進なしに生きることは成り立たない
まあついでに雑談しますけど
マッカリゴーサラという邪教の人がいて
お釈迦様がその人にはものすごく反対的に
もうもう徹底的に批判するんです
とんでもない人やと いつでも柔軟性で優しい言葉をかけるお釈迦様は
マッカリゴーサラのことになってくると
もうとんでもない人だと
あの小さな小川にでっかい罠かけてるような人間だと
もう蛇もカエルも誰も逃げられない
逃がしませんよと この人はもう大きな川でも罠を仕掛けたっても
まあいくらか魚捕まるだけでね
そういうふうに人いて
みんな地獄に落とすんだと
この人のことで何かお釈迦様がすごく非難したかというと
この因果法則はないんだと
この人言ってるんですね
ですから 人が努力すると何かに達するってことはありえないんだと
それ因果法則だから だから努力
精進というのは存在さえもしないんだよと言ってるんです
ただそのまま投げるだけだと
そこで一切努力 精進 頑張るという
頑張る 踏ん張る なんでもいいんですけど
そこは全く無意味で 存在さえもしないと言うんだから
あの人はもう断言的に
もう邪見の象徴的な邪見です
他の人々のことはなんとかもう訂正できますけどね
これは無理だと それぐらい反対しています
だから人生っていうのは精進なんですよ
呼吸することさえも精進なんですよ
それなりにエネルギー使わないと頑張らないと呼吸さえもできないんですよ
食べたものは体がすごい苦労して消化しないと
もう大変なことになるでしょうに
だから細胞一個一個ものすごくもう絶えず仕事をしているんですよ
止まらないんです 何一つも
だからこれはありえないと
存在さえもしないというのはもうあまりにもおかしい考え方なんですよ
我々は呼吸することさえも精進なんですよ
だから何一つも得られません
精進なしには 一休みはありません
人生には したがって 行動的であること
実行主義であることを優先するべきですよ
例えば今は10分ぐらい休憩を取ったでしょうに
皆さんは黙っていた？ないでしょうに
止まりはないんですよ
その時間に別なことをしただけの話で
休んだわけじゃないんです
休みはないんです だから人生に休みはないということを覚えておけば
怠けがなくなるんですよ
ということは いつでも我々人間は実行主義であること
優先しなくちゃいけないんですね
観念的な生き方は時間の無駄なので止めるんです
ただ考えるだけ生き方っていうのは時間の無駄
考えてもいいんだけど
いつでも考えが実践で成り立つのかと
いわゆる実行できるのかという
これでバランスを取らなくちゃいけないんですよ
バランス崩れちゃうと
実行できないものを考えちゃうと
病気になってしまうんです
いろいろ面白いことを考えたってもいいんだけど
これはまあ実行ということも入れておいて
そこでバランスを整えるんですよ
実行できないものを考えたら
これはただの妄想だと
そこでもうカットしなくちゃいけないんですね
嫌と思っても苦が確実にあるんです
生きることは苦なんですね
だから苦は嫌だよと言ったってもどうしようもないんです
生きることは苦なんです
それで一個一個の苦を乗り越えるんですね
障害を乗り越えることは充実ことに充実感を感じる
我々は常に絶えず問題に遭遇するんです
これで苦しくなるんです
その問題を乗り越えて乗り越える
そして次の問題に遭遇するんです
で それを乗り越える そうすると次の問題に遭遇する
問題って苦に入れ替えてください
今苦しみがあると 我々はなんとかする
なんとかしたら その苦しみを乗り越えちゃいますけど
次の苦しみが次にあるんです
そこをなんとかして乗り越えると
次の苦しみがあるんです
生きる上では苦しみの連続なんです
だから生きるということは
一個一個の苦しみを飛んで飛んで飛んで飛んでいくことなんです
苦しいんだから 何もしませんという話じゃないんです
生きることは苦しいんだから自殺してやるぞという意味じゃないんです
生きることは苦しいとは
どうやら自殺できる 自殺もっとすごい苦しいでしょうに
それは矛盾でしょうに
それで死んだからと終わりますかね
因果法則なんて終わりませんだから何一つも
これは法則嫌だから終わるっていうこと終わらない
とにかく続く 生命では何続くかというと
苦が続くんですね 吸うことも苦であって
吐くことも苦なんです
この見たり聞いたりすることも苦しいんですよ
だから微妙にこの感覚器官のね
この観察能力をすごく育ててみると
見ることも苦であって
聞くことも苦であって
味わうことも苦であって
感じるものも苦であって
苦以外何もなくないんだとわかるんです
だから何でも苦ですから
何に文句言うんですかね
仕事は苦しいんだとか
じゃあ他何かある？苦しくないもの
文句を言うところはないんですよ
仕事は苦しい では私は仕事を辞めて家で引っ込んでいるそうと
それ楽しい？それまたお金がなくても
また苦しいでしょうに
家で何もしないでいることも苦しいし
では外へ出て何かやるならば
それも結局は苦しいんですよ
だから文句を言うところないんですよ
だから文句を言う人というのは無知なんです
人生に だから一切苦であると言っている仏教の世界の人間というのは
ものすごく明るくて  人間が生きてきてよかったところ
神様の偉大なる神様の恵みだと
なんてすごい世界でしょう
見てごらんなさいと いかに神様が幸福を与えてくれるでしょうかとか
なんとか変だ この人々はすごくもう
もう悲観主義で暗いんでしょうし
この初期仏教の人々はもう洪水で自分の家が潰れちゃっても泣いたりはしません
まあどっちでも同じだと
あったってもろくな家じゃないし
潰れたってもどちらでも同じ苦しみだからまあいいやという感じで
まあ次から次のことをやるんですよ
次のことやったんだからといって
なんかすごいことそうでもないとわかってます
勉強しなきゃいけないときは勉強する
あんた勉強したらなんかすごいこと
もう宝くじが当たるようなすごいこと
いえ 別にどうってことないんだと
だからいくつかの苦悩の間で一つ選択する
学校に行って勉強するか
もう学校に行かないで不良の人々と一緒に遊ぶかと考えればわかるでしょう
どちらを選べばいいんでしょうかと
人間が楽な方を選ぶとありえないんです
理性ある人は学校に行って勉強たり
ものすごい苦しい 嫌やと
不良者としてあれもすごい苦しくて嫌やと
では この嫌なものの二者択一
どちらにするのかというと
答えははっきりしているでしょうね
お腹がすいている これは嫌ですね
苦しいでしょうね 料理を作ることはものすごく苦しくて嫌なんですね
じゃあどちらにする？決まりをはっきりして優柔不断になりません
お腹が空いているというその苦しみ
じゃあお腹が空いたままで座っているかと
これも成り立たないし
だったらもう料理作るという苦しみに決めるぞと
ああ 料理作ることなんて幸せだと
そういう馬鹿なことを思いません
幸せじゃない ややこしい
面倒くさいと しかし お腹が空いていることよりはマシだと
だから余計な頭が余計に変な妄想ないんだからすごくわかるんです
だからニコニコとできます
初めから知ってるんだからね
もう苦しいと 料理終わったらもうもう食べてからもう食べるのもそんな苦しいし
もう で それから後片付けまた苦しいし
後片付けが苦しいといって全部食器やら全部そのまま置いておくと
これが楽しいでしょうかね
それも結局苦しいでしょうね
だったらどんな苦しみにするのかと
後片付けをする苦しみにするのか
そのまま放っておく苦しみにするのかと
だから仏教的に見ると
たちまち人生はもう何のことなくスムーズに流れていくんです
というわけで 本来の怠けを何とかしなくちゃいけない
次に この過程 方法だけ気にするんですよ
目的じゃなくて 過程 方法を一番大事です
目的は瞬間のことだからね
この世で偶然 恵み ラッキー
過ぎている奇跡などはありません
皆様欲しいかもしれませんだけど
だからもう要求があるんだから
いっぱい売ってはいますけどね
全部嘘でありえないんです
奇跡とか奇跡で病気治ったとか
どこかの水 水 もう湖で水飲んだところでがんが治ったとか
とんでもない嘘です あんなのは
怠けの連中は無知な連中はそちらに走り出しますけど
理性ある人はそれなりに科学的に考えて
落ち着いて落ち着いて明るく気持ちでいると
そんなにがんっていうのは治るものだったら治りますよ
治らない状態になったらまあしょうがないんですけど
どちらでも仏教徒は楽しいんです
治ったのは治ったんだよと楽しむし
治らなかったらまあそんなもんやからね
まあどうせ死ぬんだからね
いいんじゃないかと その仏教的な生き方の明るさっていうのは
誰にも壊すことできませんよ
何をしたっても そういう人々は明るいんです
ただで努力なしで得るものはありません
これも人生論なんです
ただで得るものというのはありえないんです
努力は必要なんです 客観的な
具体的な観察と努力によってのみ目的に達するんです
客観的な具体的な観察
目的は何でしょうか？なんでこんな目的に目的を作ったのかとかね
これをよく見て それから努力する
うん ですから 何よりも過程
プロセス プロセスが大事です
目的大事ですじゃない
例えば仏教では涅槃 解脱という目的を教えているでしょうし
みんな涅槃って何でしょうかね？と説明してくれと
よくわかりませんと わかるわけないでしょうに
説明したっても お釈迦様も説明不可能ですよと言ってますから
それだけは言語に成り立ちませんと
目的どうでもいいんですよ
どうすれば達するのかという過程が大事ですよ
だから解脱したい 解脱したいと目する人は一人も成長しません
だから だって過程を無視しているでしょうに
でね 修行は正しくやっているのかということには気づかないんです
今の瞬間のことです 達しません
解脱する瞬間の出来事ですよ
しかし 修行には結構時間かかります
だから過程 プロセスですよ
大きい目的であっても
それを細分解して部品ごとに達していく
時々巨大目的を作ったとする
例えば解脱ということことは
もう最強大 もう最大の巨大目的なんですよ
輪廻を脱することだからね
生きること 乗り切ることだからね
これは一日の瞬間で はい
恵みで落ちてきたとかね
ありえません 時々日本の行者たちを言うんです
悟りっていうのは 向こう側からもう何でしたっけ？寄ってくるものだと
何言ってる？キリスト教ですかね
しかし まあこれは仏教徒ですけど
そちらで言っているのは
期待するんじゃなくて
自分の仕事を淡々とすればいいと
だから私に悟りやなんちゃらって聞くなよと
私はただ座禅しているだけやという話ですけど
向こうからやってくるという言葉はちょっと私は気に入らないだけで
本人は別に邪教を言ってるわけじゃないんです
ただ言葉下手だけで 我々のブッダ
ブッダの立場から見れば
それは正しく言える いう方法ありますよ
経験もしていない目的を妄想したっても
これは成り立たないんだから
今何やるべきかということに今集中しているんだよと
今やるべきことをやらないと
目的何であろうと達するわけじゃないんだと
だから悟りについて聞くなよと
わかりませんと まだ達してないんだと
今忙しいんだと そのために
ですから 例えば悟りという巨大目的であっても細分解するんですよ
だから一番最初にできることって何でしょうかと
心を清らかにすることだから
では嘘をつかないとかね
殺生しないとかね 酒取らないとかね
そういう風に普通一番基本的なところでリスタートと
それでできることでしょうに
嘘をつかないで頑張ると
当然心 綺麗になるんだから
なるほどそれなりに綺麗になるんだから
悟りっていうのは完全な綺麗な綺麗な境地であるならば
いくらか精進選択を始めているんだということになるでしょうに
そこはできるようになったら
いろいろ集中力に挑戦して
それから観察能力にも挑戦して
順番に進めばよろしいということで
他の俗世間の目的であっても
巨大目的ばっかり現象で見るんじゃなくて
これを細分解して小さく小さく分解して
できるところからスタートして
次へ次へ次へ行くんですよ
それがやり方なんですね
将来のことを完全に忘れて
今自分が行うことは目的に導くのかと調べるんです
将来はもうきれいさっぱり忘れるんです
今やっていることは導きますかと
目的に それはチェックできますからね
因果法則の理解が必要ですね
それから目的に達するためには
どんな目的であろうとも因果法則が大事なんです
野球のプロになりたいという目的を作っても
それは因果法則で成り立っているんです
ですから 野球のプロになるための原因は何なのか
条件は何なのかとかね
そこを覚えておけば わかっておけば
自分に実行できるかないかということがわかってきますね
原因と条件という 2つが揃ったら結果が現れるんですからね
これは因果法則なんですね
だから因果法則で全てうまくいくんです
はい 次に行きます それから目的について語ります
あの曖昧な目的 不浄な目的ってダメと言ったんだからね
目的っていうのは正しい目的
目的は正しくないならば
達するより失敗した方が良いんです
自分の目的が正しくないんだったら
やっぱり失敗した方がありがたいんですよ
正しくない目的に達したらもう大変なことになりますからね
たとえそれほど良くない目的に挑戦したところで
失敗で終わったら助かりましたと思わなくてはならないんですよ
人間というのはいい加減だから
時々自分でも知ってますよ
これ悪い目的やと 悪い目的は知っているのに挑戦するでしょうに
悪い目的だとわかって挑戦したところで失敗する
そうすると落ち込んじゃうんですよ
そのとこ落ち込んではならない
ああ よかった 助かりましたと
本当は辞められなくていたんだと
これで全部バレちゃって大変なことになって
奥さんに怒られて もう家から追い出されちゃって
もうもうそれでよかったと思わなきゃダメなんです
正しい目的であっても
自分に管理できない原因条件も絡むので
その時の失敗は失敗ではありません
これは俗世間の話で 仏道は自分で管理できますけどね
何かやろうとしても 自分だけの努力で行くわけじゃないんです
自分に関係ない他の原因もいっぱいあります
例えば ものすごくよく勉強したならば
いい仕事あるんだよと思っても
その社会の経済状況が悪くて
新しい何でしたっけ  人を雇わないことになりましたと
今回は日本の会社はもう大学卒業生を使用しないことになりましたと
もう経済状態は最悪だとというと
自分がせっかく勉強したのに仕事がない
大失敗ではないんですよ
それは自分の原因じゃないんだから
なんてバカなことをしたんでしょうかと自分はと思わなくていいんです
だから いろんなことで自分が頑張ってはいるんだけど
環境の原因っていうのは自分にはどうすることもできない場合もありますので
その時の失敗は失敗ではありません
自分に本当に必要なもの
なくてはならない なくては困るもの
困るものです 正しい目的っていうのは
だから目的は曖昧でダメですよ
目的を作る場合は この目的は私にとっては必要だよと
なくてはならないんだよと
なくなくなくては困るんだという目的は正しいんです
皆様の様々な目的あるでしょうね
なくて困る目的も困らない目的もあるでしょうね
逆に目的に達したら困るということもあるんじゃないんですかね
だから目的に達したら困る
目的は正しい目的じゃないんです
まあなくてもどうったことない目的は目的じゃないんです
なくてはならない なくては困るという目的が正しい目的ですよ
それぐらいのことには誰にでも挑戦できる
成功もできる 自分だけじゃないんですね
また 周りに他人に必要なもの
なくてはならないもの
なくては困るもの 困るものも正しい目的ですよ
自分ではなくて他人のこと
これが他人に対しては必要なもの
なくてはならないもの
なくては困るものだとわかると
それも正しい目的なんですね
だから人は自分のためにも他人のためにも行動はします
そういうことで その 2つで正しい目的を設定するんです
それからまたあります
自分の人格を向上させる目的
正しいんです 心の汚れをなくす目的も正しい目的です
智慧になる目的などですね
正しい目的 これは正しい目的で
これははっきりしなくちゃいけない
優柔不断でもダメ 曖昧でもダメ
正しくない目的の場合はかなり問題は起きます
正しい目的を設定した場合
自然にやる気が出ます
決して何でしたっけ？止めたくはないんです
もし我々に正しい目的を設定することができれば
もうやる気なんかもうあるんです
なぜなくては困るんだから
必要だから だから正しい目的を設定することで
やる気 勇気っていうものは何のことなく出ているんです
だから 俗世間でやる気がないということは
目的は正しくないんです
汚れています だから挫折するんです
仏教の世界では挫折は認めません
えらい頑固です 仏教はとにかく目的に達するまでもう諦めません
それってしつこいとかしつこくはないんです
目的自体が正しいんだからね
エネルギーは自然にあるんです
もう止まりません 止めても誰かが
自分も充実感を感じる
それ正しい目的を設定した時点で
あ 自分は我ながら結構立派なことをことをやっているのではないかという充実感が出てくる
食うとか何とか もうもうもう全然もう関係なくなっちゃうんです
あ 何か間違ったね 周りも励ましたり応援したりする
自分の目的が正しければ
周りの人々もよく応援してくれます
協力してくれます 悪い目的だったらみんな非難して足を引っ張る
引っ張ってやらせないようにする
だから周りは応援してくれるわ
協力してくれるわ 自分でも元気であるし
で 目的に達しますよ もう挫折することがなくなっちゃうんですね
邪魔をする人がいても
その人に負けてはならないと
さらに勇気が出てくる
それでも邪魔な邪魔をする人々がいたら
自分がこんな立派な目的で頑張ってますからね
この人に負けたらもう最悪やと
ああ 嫌だ もうもう批判する人がいるんだ
足を引っ張る人がいるんだ
いや やめたって それはありえません
こんな立派な目的だからね
この人に負けちゃうともう情けないってことで
邪魔があったら 邪魔も結局は自分のエネルギーの資源になっちゃうんです
お釈迦様にとっても 結構悪魔とかいろいろ邪魔邪魔したんですけど
お釈迦様とそれで勇気が湧いてくるで
いろいろお坊さんたちが修行する時でも
いろいろなエピソードがいくつかありますけども
悪魔が出てきてむちゃくちゃ邪魔すると
邪魔すると お坊さんたちがこれこれ悪魔やとわかるんでしょうし
わかったら元気になるんです
ああ 嫌だ 悪魔が来て邪魔するんだから瞑想できないじゃなくて
あ なるほど 俺は立派に頑張ってるんじゃないか
だったらだからこいつは出てきたんだと
じゃあやるぞと 見てみろと
お前に勝ちますよということで
そこはまた返って悪魔にはものすごい悔しい
悔しいんだけど 本人が勝ちます
この前にもこの同じ場所である一つエピソードを言いましたけど
もう一度繰り返しますけど
あるお坊さんが あの そんなにまあもう頭のいいお坊さんというわけでもなくて
自分の修行の一つとして
毎日お寺をきれいに掃除する
このお寺といっても外のところだからね
菩提樹とかいろいろありますからね
そういうところは一生懸命発光しますから
もう朝も昼も一切れで綺麗に掃除して
すごい気分いい状況を作るんです
それでお坊さんたちは心の喜びを感じる
しかし この悪魔がこの人
毎日欠かすこのことをやってるんだと
見たら この人はこれで結構修行しているとわかったんですね
ただ掃除するだけで 心はずっと綺麗なままで保っている
念仏ですね ブッダを念じて念じて修行瞑想しているんですね
瞑想として何をやるのかというと
箒を持って掃除をするだけ
だから日本の念仏ほどかっこいいものじゃないかもしれません
太鼓はないし シンバルもないし
何もないんだからね ピアノもないし
ただまあコツコツと掃除しているだけでも
このお坊さんはもう染色として念仏で瞑想しているんです
これでマーラさんが来たら
この人の心はなんかすごい綺麗やと
邪魔してやるぞと 汚してやるぞと来たんで
どうやって来たかというと
すごい醜いボロボロの年取ってる牛の形に変身して来たんです
来て お坊さんがずっと苦労して掃除終わったところで
どこか分からないところで牛が来て
下痢ボロボロボロボロボロボロと
もう水の如く下痢を出して
全部一回りして どこか知らないところに亡くなっちゃうんです
下痢だから これなかなか綺麗にすることもできないし
それでお坊さんは何のことなく
すーっとまたゆっくりゆっくり
一つ一つ取り出して またものすごい気分いい環境に戻しちゃったんです
戻って終わって あ 綺麗に終わったなと喜びを感じる束の間に
またどこかであの牛が来るんですね
見る限り気持ち悪い牛で
見ても腹が立つような
えらいかっこ悪い牛で
それで足が 年だからね
足がボロボロで ゆっくりゆっくりあっち行ったりこっち行ったり
あれこれで全部またいっぱい下痢を出して
またこれ一回 二回 二回もなっても理解できますけど
その三回目にちょうど時間にくる
それで あら この計算見事に合ってますよと
いくらなんでもこれはありえないんだと
お坊さんが自分の心の清らかさをなくさなかったんです
逆に理性があったんだから
あれ？私は今二 三時間苦労したんだけど
この計算 なんで見事に合っているのかと
これはおかしいと お坊さん
牛が来たら君 本当は何者？と聞いたんですね
聞いたら あの 皆様と違って悪魔さえも嘘だけは言いませんよ
神々も嘘はつかないんです
あくまで言っても天国の一番トップのクラスですから
もう善行をしなきゃ生まれてきませんよ
そちらも だから嘘はつきません
何者と聞いちゃうと あの
実は私はまあこういうマーラですけど
ああそうですかと ああ
よかったよかった 会って会ってよかったと
行って このお坊さん その人と喋るんですね
仲良し会話するんです
悪魔って言ったら 大人はキリスト教の映画なんかに出てくるような感じじゃないんで
はっ 会ってよかったと
仏教だから何でもいい方向に見るんだからね
あ 会ってよかったと ということは
君はそういう昔からいるでしょうね
うん そうですよ 私たちの寿命が長いんだから
だから君 お釈迦様にも会ったことあるでしょうね
羨ましいですね うん よく会いましたよと
それとお坊さんが頭の中で
もうお釈迦様って誰も見たことはないんですね
仏像があってもお釈迦様ではないんだからね
この人は見たことがあるんだから
また神でしょうしね いろいろ作ることはできるし
これはお願いしてみようと
言ったら お釈迦様ってどういう形ですかね
あんたもうすごい神だからね
その姿作ってくれることできるでしょうにと言ったら
いえ できませんと言ったら恥ずかしいでしょうね
面子がないんでしょうね
言ったら でも私たちみたいな人々が作っても
なんかもうちょっと難しいんだと
このお釈迦様悟ってるんだからね
その完全悟った人を肉体は作ってもね
もういろんなことありますからね
まあそれはちょっともうできませんと
言って いえ それは構いませんよと
完璧でなくても まあいくらか
まあ形だけでも見せてくださいと
そしたらはい わかりますと言って
お釈迦様が本当のお釈迦様の形を見せたんですね
こんな形でしたと言ったら
このお坊さんが こいつは最悪の人が作った
この姿でも幻想でもこんなにすごいんだと
もしこれが完全たる心清らかにした証覚者であるブッダそのものだったら
いかにすごいでしょうと
もう感動しちゃって そこで心が清らかになっちゃって
煩悩がなくなって悟っちゃったんです
悪魔は何しに来たのかと
だから悪魔が来たんだからといって
負け 仏教徒は負けません
誰にも たとえ悪魔が来たっても
これうまく使うんです
だから それは理性的な生き方ということなんですよ
だから我々日常の世界の中でも
正しい目的があると 邪魔する人っていうのは邪魔じゃないんです
足を引っ張る人っていうのはなくなっちゃうんです
これをうまく使って 自分の目的に達するんです
それで皆様方 私はいろいろ目的を書いたでしょうに
で 皆様に関心がある 健康で長生きする目的とかね
大金持ちになる目的とかでなかったね
人格向上とか心を清らかにすることは正しい目的だと
まあそういうことだから
やっぱり俗世間の目的についてもちょこっと語ります
あの これはやっぱり二面性があるんですよ
例えば金持ちになりたい
人気者になりたい 政治家になりたい
タレントさんになりたいとかね
そういう俗世間の目的はね
結婚したいとかね には
いつでも二面性があることは覚えておいてください
勉強する 結婚する 金を儲かるなどの俗世間的な目的をも我々にはあるんですからね
これは無視はできません
だからね この目的に達したら幸せだ
幸福だだけというわけにはいきません
この俗世間の目的からは
皆様には逃げることはできません
俗世間にいるんだから
金がなくなっちゃう 誰も食べさせてくれないしね
だから金儲けしなくちゃいけないし
頭が悪い 勉強してない人だから助けてあげも誰も思わないんだからね
ですから 勉強もしなくちゃいけないし
そういうわけで まあ結婚したいとか
勉強したいとか 仕事をしたいとか
金を儲けたいっていうのは
俗世間の目的から我々はなかなか逃げたくても逃げられません
やらなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし そちら我々よく失敗するんですよ
結婚したら私はもう何もいらん
それで幸せやという これとんでもないことなんですよ
そう言うんだから 若い娘さんたちは
平気で あの人とすごい気に入ってる人を見つけたんだから
あの人と結婚すればもう何もいりませんよと
じゃあそれはちょっとした頭の悪い表現なんですよ
子供は一生の頼みだからとか頼むでしょうに
両親に それはうまくかった方がいいんですよ
では書いてくれと あなたの一生の頼みですと
これ以上何も頼みませんと
でもそう簡単に子供には勝てませんだから子供はその場合はそれ引き下げますからね
まあどっちにしろってもね
親がね 子供は一生の頼み頼みということ
親がやってあげたいことだから
結局はね だからまあそれでまあどちらでも勝ち負けなく問題は解決しますけど
その場合はじゃあ書いてくれと
ちゃんと これは私の一生の頼みですと
だから まあそういうふうなことは成り立たないんですよ
で 我々はそちらでかなり失敗して挫折するんですよ
これさえできればとか
金持ちになったならば
これだけ幸せやと じゃないんです
二面性があるんです 悪い面
不幸になる面もあるんですからね
それも覚えておきましょうということで
挑戦する前に長所も短所も考慮するんですよ
結婚したらもう何もいりません
これこそ幸せじゃなくて
結婚したらどうなるのかとかね
この相手の本当の性格が見えてきたらどうなるのかとかね
いろいろ考慮しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこは今日考えた上で結婚すると失敗しないんですよ
そういうところを初めから読みがありましたと
例えば結婚する前には
男ってすごい親切でしょうしね
言うこと何でもやってくれるし
まあ今日は買い物したいんですけど
一緒についてくれるかっていうと
ついていくんですよ そこで服を入れ替えるわ
もう何着と言うんですか
あの試着でしたっけ？着てみろ
いや これはダメ これはちょっと赤すぎ
あ これはちょっとピンク色
これはこれは緑があるんで
これダメとかね もうとにかくもうデパートの着るもの全部着てみたっても気に入るものなくて
やっぱりダメだ 次の店に行きましょうとかね
これでも 2 3時間振り回されますけど
もうすごくニコニコしてますよ
それで勘違いしてはいけません
結婚してからもうそうやってくれると
だからこのいろんなこと
出来事はありますということはね
子供が欲しいだけではなくて
子供が生まれてきたらどういうことになるのかとかね
そういうところを最初からもう知った人がしっかりやるんです
無批判的にまっしぐらに目的に挑戦するのではなく
危険性を減らす方法もプロセスの一部です
目的があったら まっしぐらに目的に向かって挑戦するんじゃないんです
このこのプロセスのプログラムの一部ですよ
この危険性も この危険性はどうすれば減らすのかと
途中で嫌になって諦めることはなくなるんですよ
すると 正しく生きること
人格向上を本職で本当の目的であると理解しておけば
他の目的は副業で達すれば悪くない程度になるんです
これは仏教的な最終的な答えなんです
人間の本業は 本職は 人格向上して解脱することなんですよ
それ以外すべて副業ですからね
まああって悪くないと
その程度で十分ですよ
結婚できれば悪くないんだと
とにかくではないんです
うん まああっても悪くない程度で目的を作ればいいんです
はい 次のポイントに行きます
心の柔軟性ということ
どうすれば心の柔軟性
まず どのようにでも心は伸びるものだとまず理解してほしい
できるかできないか置いておいて
心っていうのはどのようにも伸びますよと
堕落すれば極悪人にもなるし
成長すれば解脱にも達するんです
同じ心は どこかで読んだ覚えがあるんですけど
ある画家が あの ジェイсус様の絵を描いたかったんですね
そうするとモデルが必要ですからね
で この人は人を探して探して探して
なんかすごく心穏やかな
見る限り この人ならジェイсус様のモデルにいいやと
もって人を選んでモデルにして絵を描いたんですね
それでまた時間経ったところで
イエス様だけじゃなくて
なんかもう一人いるんですね
イエス様を売ってしまった人
ジュダスでしたっけね
で 金に目がくらんじゃってという当時の話ね
今なんかジュダスの立場がまた復活したみたいですけど
で いわゆる極悪人の絵も描いたかったんですね
完全無欠の人の絵を描いてから
もう完全にダメな人の絵も描いてやるぞと
それでまたモデルを探すんですね
人を見つかったんですよ
見つけてモデルにして絵を描いたんですね
描いてる途中で その人に私はかなり何年か前でね
このようにこのモデルをとってね
こういう絵も描いたことがありますよと言ったら
この人はあのね あのモデルになったの私ですけど
と言ったそうで 結局同じ人を選んじゃったんですね
2番目にも そのストーリーは何のためにあったかというと
この心次第やと だからなんでこうなって
当時で私はまともな人間でしたけど
それ人生は狂っちゃって最悪人間になりましたと
そういうわけで 結局は心はどちらにでもなるんだよということで
そういうキリスト教文化の中でも
やっぱりそういうストーリーはあるんです
どこで読んだかちょっと覚えてないんですけどね
能力の制限はほとんど寿命で決めるんですよ
だから 画家になるためにも
まあやっぱりまあせいぜい 5 6
年かかるんだったら ピアニストになるためにも10年かかるんだったら
やっぱりね 時間は 24時間しかないし
能力はどれぐらい自分で決めますよ
別に心は弱いわけじゃないんです
寿命は短いので目的の選択が必要なんですよ
これよく覚えてください
何でもじゃなくて 我々の寿命ってのはすごい短いんですよ
だからたくさん目的もあるし
やれば何でもできるし
それで何をするのかという
正しく選択するんですよ
他の希望はきれいさっぱりカットするんです
だから心に無制限に能力あるんだけど
我々の寿命は短いんだから
目的を選択して 他一切もうないことにしてカットするんです
頭の中で妄想としてでも使ってはいけないんです
それからまあちょこっと仏教の話に入りますけど
例えば私は今日言わないということにしておいたんですけど
勉強するときに頭が硬くなると言ったでしょうね
だからどうしましょうかと
勉強やめますか？と そうじゃないんですよ
人格向上ということを覚えておけば
柔軟性は持てます 我々は何を学んでも
それによって人間を学ぶんだと
自分の人格を向上させるんだよと思ってみれば
学問で頭が硬くならない
例えば英語を勉強すると
それなりに英語を喋る人々のことも気持ちも理解して
よく物事を理解できる人間になりますよと
それでドイツ語を勉強したら
ドイツ人の好き嫌い 好み
生き方などなど 考え方などなどを理解して
さらに人間を理解できる人間になろうではないかというと
柔軟性なんです そうすると見事にできるようになるんです
形だけ畳むんだからね
また日本学と一緒にできなくなっちゃうんです
日本学を入れることで遮断するんで
自分の心 他のことは勉強しないぞと
硬くなるぞと そういうことで
科学であろうが数学であろうが
化学であろうが どんな学問の中でも
なんかどこかで人間性を語ってますよ
だから発展しようと思えばいくらでも発展できます
歴史を勉強したっても
ほとんど事実じゃなくてからくりです
歴史っていうのはね やっぱり歴史を勉強しながら
まあ昔の人っていうのはいかにバカでしたとかね
そんなことやったって死んじゃったでしょうとかね
もっとあっちなことできなかったんでしょうかとかね
人間性勉強すれば 地理学
地球のことを勉強してもね
我々偉そうな人間やと思ってこういるんですけどね
地球の方はね すごい巨大で
まあどうにもならんとも手に負えないんだと
そういう方向で自分の気持ちを持っていくと
スーッと一貫して人格向上っていうものあるんですよ
それで心は柔軟性であるんです
そこでいろんなことを勉強できるようになります
それが学問のやり方 正しいやり方なんです
それで仏教でいうと この不善心所というものがありますよ
心に汚れが入るんですよ
それでカチッと硬くなるんですね
不善心所っていうのは 14あります
今日は時間ないんだから説明しませんだけど
痴と無惨 無記 情 好欲 それから見解
まあちょこちょこっていくらか説明しますけど
この無惨っていうのはね
もうもうバカでね もう怖いものない
もう恥ずかしいものない
やるぞというね これではもう汚れたものに飛び込むことだから
とんでもないんですよ
切っていうのは怖がらないっていうことでね
悪いことはもう怖がらないでやると
そういうのは良くないし
それでこの情っていうのは心を定めませんね
混乱状態 優柔不断状態で
欲は欲で 欲だったらもう固めますね
これは見解 見解っていうのは偏見で真理を見ないということでしょうし
そういうもので 慢やら瞋
怒り 嫉妬 物惜しみ 後悔
昏沈 睡眠 疑 で14 たった 14ですよ
それでギュッと心が硬くなるんです
もう動かなくなっちゃうんです
それで不幸になるんです
これは不善だから どうしても悪
悪にもなります だから心からこれを取り除けばいいんですよ
これが自分を支配しないようにと気をつけることは柔軟になるんです
やりやすいんですよ まあ欲はないようにと
怒りはないようにと 混乱はないようにと
後悔はないようにと １４項目でそれ気をつければいいんです
それで知っていうのは無知だから
いつでも理性でということで
牛のお坊さんとの話を考えて
たとえ悪魔が来たっても
理性ある人は勝っちゃいますからね
そんなところですね 善心は ２５ありますが
省略します もうちょっとまあたくさんですからね
善心よりも悪 悪い心情をね
覚えて そこは捨てることを決めれば
それでも終わりですよ
で 共通するところをまとめると
明るさ 喜びを感じること
心の軽さなどです 柔軟性も善心の一つです
だから良いことをするっていうことは
すごく明るくていることなんですよ
心は柔軟性ですごく軽く生きることなんです
だからニコッと笑って生活できれば心は綺麗ですよ
すごい大胆な難しいことじゃないんです
常に明るくポジティブで楽しみを感じながら生きることで解決します
心は柔軟性になる場合は
明るくポジティブでいれば楽しみを感じなくちゃいけないんですよ
楽しみというのは 生きることは楽しくないんです
苦ですよ 何が楽しいんですかというと
この負けない とにかく飛んで飛んで飛んでいく
慈しみは生きるために強烈なパワーになります
慈しみっていうのは生命に対する優しさでしょうね
これっていうのはものすごいパワーなんですよ
このいや もうちょっとしたことで興奮しちゃって
ヒステリーを起こす もう何か問題あったらもう何もできない
女性の立ち女性の方々は子供を育ててるだけではもう怖い
あまりにもパワー持ってます
もう決して怖いものは知らない
何でもやる 普段はちょっとしたことでも怯えたりしてね
キャーと泣いたりとかね
引き下がりますけど あの力はどこから出てくるんですかね
子供に何かあると 子供を守るためにはどんな糸とも言ってぶつかるんです
誰にでも文句を言うんです
怖くないんですよ 相手が虎であっても行って蹴っ飛ばす
普通だったら虎の写真を見ただけでも怖いと思っちゃいますよ
なのに 例えば自分の子供が虎に刺され襲われるようになっちゃうと
もう行って虎を蹴っ飛ばすんだからね
いや これてめえ出ていけと
その力はどこから出てきますか？それ
子供を愛してるんだから
子供には不幸をさせたくないという慈しみです
だからこれっていうのはものすごい強烈なパワーなんで
だからお釈迦様はとことん慈しみを育てなさいと言ってます
それから智慧で生きるということはね
智慧で生きるということは
理性で生きるということですよ
この世間の話には乗らないんですよ
智慧の人は 世間というのは馬鹿だからね
いいこと良いことは言わない
普遍的な物事を観察する
例えば 人が何を言っても
それは主観的で一方的な意見に過ぎないと
人ということに左右される
誘惑されるんじゃなくて
それはその人の主観で一方的な見方だから
まあどうそうということで
あまり乗らない みんな貪瞋痴に覆われているにも関わらず
世直しのことを語る 当てにならないと理解するんです
みんなできるわけもないのに
貪瞋痴で覆われて何も右も左もわからないのに
よく世なすのことを語っているんだから
こんなのは理性のある人は乗りません
一切は無常で 常に変化する
止まらないということも覚えておく
それぐらいやればもう立派な理性人ですよ
異星人ではなくて ですから
物事に固執しない すべて無常で止まらないでしょうに
だから物事に固執しない
無常で変わりますから
固執したってもう亡くなっているんだからね
なんかシャボン玉を握ったような感じだから
あれは壊れますからね
握った意味がない だから執着の意味がないとわかるんですよ
執着もほどほどにということですね